while Americans hope the country will be
reopened leaders are calling for
widespread antibody tests to fight the
corona virus the blood tests may be able
to find out if someone who had corona
virus is now immune to it so this could
help determine who can safely resume a
normal life but questions still remain
over whether this test can accurately
determine immunity and how long that
immunity lasts our senior medical
correspondent that's dr. Tara Narula
shows us how this test works if we were
able to quickly test people's antibodies
and show that with the antibody keeps
the virus away we can start getting
people back to work dr. matthew sims is
the director of infectious disease
research at beaumont health in michigan
he's leading a study to test blood
samples from more than 40,000 healthcare
workers through a few drops of blood the
tests can determine if someone has built
up antibodies to fight off the virus
which could be a sign of immunity to
prevent reinfection but it remains
unclear how long that immunity will last
dr. Mike Ryan is the executive director
of the World Health Organization's
emergency programs one would expect that
a person who is generates a full-blown
immune response with the detectable
antibodies should have protection for a
period of time we just don't know what
that period of time is Beaumont hospital
nurse Zena Kasab is getting tested even
though she hasn't had any symptoms
she says wide-scale testing is important
to understand the scope of this pandemic
I have young children I have people in
my life that are over the age of 65 with
comorbidities as well and I want to know
that if I've been exposed what I can do
to continue to protect my family and to
continue to serve our community testing
like this is being done across the
country but with little federal
oversight accuracy is a concern
the FDA has only officially approved one
test how accurate is the tests that you
have now you know we believe it's in the
high nineties you know no test is
perfect you're always going to have some
false negatives you're always
have some false positives do you think
that antibody tests can give a false
sense of security
anything can give a false sense of
security we still would recommend taking
reasonable precautions even if you have
any minute
Tara Tara everybody I know is raising
their hands saying test me test me
please do you have any sense of when
this test will be widely available to
everybody
unfortunately Gill we don't know when it
will be widely available and it really
comes down to two things one is how
rapidly and efficiently we can scale up
production of the tests but more
important is how accurate are these
tests and we need to validate that what
we don't want to do is have tests out
there that are telling people they're
negative when they're positive and
they're positive when they're negative
that would be a big problem the other
factors that we need to figure out and
time will tell us this is really how
protected are you with the antibody so
just because you have a positive
antibody test does that offer you a
strong level of protection and how long
will you be immune for ultimately this
is a good thing the antibody tests are
going to tell us how widespread the
pandemic is they'll help us reopen our
economy and they will really provide
that bridge until we get a vaccine yeah
let's hope they can figure it out sooner
rather than later thank you very much
Tara